hi i'm charlie day i'm here with
buzzfeed and i'm going i sound like i
said buzzfeed hi i'm charlie today i'm
here with buzzfeed and i'm going to read
my thirst tweets here they come
all right here we go dear buzzfeed celeb
please get charlie day to read thirst
tweets i love him so much and he needs
to know how much i want to lick him like
a popsicle
what charlie day i'm free on tuesday for
you to run me over with your car please
let me know if you can run me over with
your car on tuesday when i am free so
you can sue me nice try pal when charlie
day does that lopsided smile i dot dot
dot
i'm very gay
cool charlie day i'm going to wrestle
you throw you to the ground and then
stomp on you
affectionate pass anyone just want to
suck charlie days titty just the one huh
okay charlie day is my son and my moon
my day man and my nightmare i dig it
thank you very much [ __ ] you netflix for
not having one charlie day film i just
want to watch a movie with my daddy in
it i'm not your daddy i would give my
left nut to meet charlie day in real
life don't do that it's not worth it
charlie day's dramatic acting in pacific
rim is getting me hyped to sell my blood
juice
what does that mean i and many other
poor women like me am dying to [ __ ]
early day dying to death
awesome that's great i would pay good
money to chew on the gum charlie day
spits out
come on man that's bad that's nasty not
to be horny on maine
but leather jacket ear piercing young
charlie day please pin me up against the
wall and
okay next time be more descriptive
please why do i heavily nut over charlie
day i don't know i don't know you must
have a healthy diet can i just meet
charlie day please i need to tell him i
loved him in the lego movie all right
well we don't have to meet i feel like
you just told me so thank you i
appreciate it charlie day this is all
caps charlie day please answer my texts
uh sir ma'am i don't believe i'm getting
your texts charlie day could choke and
kill me with a piano wire and i would
thank him
people are dark man what not safe for
work question mark i'm sorry god i want
charlie today to call me daddy so badly
i'm so sorry uh
you know you don't have to apologize to
god for that that's fine no big deal
that was interesting people use some
very descriptive language i'm not a i'm
not on twitter so these haven't made
their way to me um happy i read them
happy you guys are out there and uh and
feeling passionate this is great really
uh filled my cup so to speak check out i
want you back on amazon prime video
february 11th
[Music]
you